hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled implementation of
molecular diagnostics for SARS Kovach to
this webinar is part of the ongoing
coronavirus virtual webinar series
presented by lions
I am Kaylee Bach of leopards and I will
be a moderator for today's event now
let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you'd
like during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask question
box and click then we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits time located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now presented a speaker dr.
Lee Jung Szechwan Academy of Medical
Sciences Sichuan provincial People's
Hospital Sichuan provincial center for
clinical laboratories dr. Zhang you may
now begin your presentation
hello everyone I'm Lee Jung from Sichuan
provincial People's Hospital in China
I'm very glad sheering our experiences
and a study of molecular diagnostics for
South Korea to during this pandemic
first let me introduce our hospital
system provincial People's Hospital it
is one of the largest government
hospitals in Sichuan province
established in 1941 to date our Hospital
has more than four thousand beds and
near 7,000 employees we serve uniformed
minion outpatients and 120,000 in
patients per year okay as we know by the
end of this March a pandemic of CO 819
cost more than 750,000 Comfort cases of
CO a 19 and 36,000 deaths around world
we are facing very serious situation
because of the virus so today I will
share how we established nuclear I see
testing for Sasuke we - in our lab then
I will talk about our study to answer
question related to elastic efficiency
of live as a testing this goes through
the even Sakura the very beginning the
pandemic which are related to molecular
diagnostic testing for Sasuke we - the
outbreak was first reported at n log
2019
by January 7th Sasuke we - virus was
identified by Chinese scientists fine
five days later Chinese CDC released the
virus genome e sequence which made
clinical labs and manufactures possible
to develop nuclear IC testing for Aris
on January 16th the first bench of
commercial rt-pcr test kits were
distributed to Wuhan and three days
later to other provinces cross country
include our Sichuan province actually
our lab studied running the tests on
general three twenties in the first
period of the outbreak all tests were
completed by channels in DC and public
health labs over time the testing wall-e
rapidly increased and the National
Health Commission decided to allow or
local qualified lives to perform the
testing including Hospital clinical labs
and independent lives at the same time
Chinese FDA provide emergency use
authorization to everything manufacture
on January 26 first shoot three rt-pcr
kids were certified by CFDA on January
29th our lab was appointed as a
reference lab for Sasuke we - by Sutra
and Prevention Health Commission
actually from identification of the
worst to first destroy nuclear IC
testing certified spending less than 20
days it was a remark was successful in
molecular diagnostics of infectious
disease so our lab established this IC
in three steps fortunately when we
decided to run nucleus a test for the
virus there were few commercial rt-pcr
test gates available
thus we selected two kids
based on targeting genes internal
controls Limited's of detection levels
and RNA extraction methods after quick
validation with quality controls and run
100 clinic specimens with two testicles
parallel we eventually established the
IC in one day which has tied these three
targets genes South keeping genes as
internal control and 200 copying per
mail for limit of detection level and
automated extraction Ezzor then we build
a routine workflows of the test for our
lab the whole process could finish in
four to five hours but including
specimen transport and waiting for lab
specimen to run together real turnaround
time you learn a varied from five to
eight hours in our life as we know the
virus not much especially in the very
early period we took biosafety level 2
for lab and a biosafety level 3 or level
personnel who handled primary
respiratory specimens we also upgraded
our extraction space to lacking pressure
on the later we did 556 degree for four
minutes treatment for all respiratory
specimens to inactive virus there is
earning affection to the results
actually we did not find but there are
some
and lab reported so we had a recommended
you untested new liable before you use
this inactivation step to protect our
open space central lab from
contamination by Co 819 patient spends
samples we set up sasuke we two state
lab in a separate room to run regular
tests for kobe 19 patients lab
technician working in this lab have to
take biosafety level 3 the lab run 24
hours a day and a 7 day awake so to
ensure test quality and biosafety we
trained lab personnel in our lab and
also in more than 300 labs in Sichuan
Province online anyway our lab is also
suits on prevention center for clinical
labs responsible for providing EQA
and the guide lab quality control
through these three steps we established
the nuclear IC test in our life our
molecular biology lab could run 300
tests every day and we serve 24 hours
for clinic every day so who should be
tested for Sasuke we - in China our
national clinical guidelines of Kuwait
19 strictly defined two groups of people
first group is suspect cases who have
epidemic history and clinical symptoms
and size the second group is persons who
have academic history but no Kobe 19
patient
symptoms so to identify the on
symptomatic cases could facilitate early
diagnosis early quarantine and early
management then to prevent to the virus
transmission further so the nuclear IC
testing has played a significant role in
this endemic however a few concerns
about his detection efficiency have
raised the since army clinical
implementation in my second part I will
share our large cohort study they hope
to answer the questions related to die
elastic efficiency of nuclei assay
testing so the questions in need to be
answer are which types of specimens are
optimal for the nuclear IC testing and
when used Optima turn of specimen
collection for initial diagnosis of cove
819 when how many specimens should be
consecutively collected to improve
initial diagnostic efficiency are there
any more reliable methods available for
early diagnosis of cobra 219 besides
nuclear IC testing so we are going to
answer this question based on studying
koa 19 patient in Sichuan Province
Citroen is the province located at
southwest of China total population is
about 80 million as for much nice
there were 539 lab confirmed patients so
our investigation included 532 patients
with full recording the majority patient
of patients was moderate cases they are
seventy five point two percent and the
rest include the mild severe and
critical cases were nine point two
percent nine point six percent and 6
percent they're severe and the critical
cases together for fifteen point two
percent and there were four thousand two
hundred seventy five leoch the ISEE test
the results from the 532 patients
included in the study the top three
sample types are 46.7% throat swab 23.4%
sputum and a certain point four percent
faces lay so far ejo swabs were always
7.4 percent nasal swabs were five point
nine percent and very few specimens
include two person blood and point four
person valve so the result of this tool
and not very accurate accurate actually
so out of the four thousand two hundred
seventy five test results
there were aha 1605 were positive the
positive rates was thirty seven point
five percent which is consistent with
previous reported data so since such
solo such low that positive reads
actually has been criticized a lot so to
find out which assessment types have
our detection efficiency we compared the
positive rates among seven specimen
types of nasopharyngeal swabs and sputum
or tops three their positive rates were
77.8% 40.4% and a 39.8% throat swabs and
nasal swabs a followed were certainly
8.5%
and a 35.9% positive so ranking fourth
and the fifth the positive rate of faces
is 34.1% blood was only five percent
positive so we compared the three upper
respiratory tract specimens there were
no difference but actually upper
respiratory tract specimens was
significant lower than that of sputum
but significantly higher than that of
the pieces so according to our results
and concerned both detection efficiency
and come variance sputum and upper
respiratory tract specimens should be
used for nuclear I see testing so then
to eat Lou sedate Sasuke we to positive
rates at different disease stages
withdraw daily positive reads of upper
respiratory tract specimens sputum
phases and overall specimens between
five days before and forty days after
some time a set the Sasuke we too
nuclear IC test positive rate for
overall specimens showed as the empty
bar the presented as a u-shape cross
that disease caused with the first peak
around 85 percent to nine ninety five
percent from three days before to three
days after symptom onset the button is
around 20% at 50 to 20 days after
something else ate under the second the
peak was around 35 percent at 35 days
after symptoms it and both upper
respiratory tract specimens and sputum
the similar pattern of the positive
restraint as overall specimen to cross
the disease causes but the positive
rates of sputum always higher than the
upper respiratory tract the specimens as
showing the speaker faces swab shows
continued decrease from the sometimes
said to the end of the disease cause
actually there's paper reported at the
same trend and suggest the faces may
little Barris loading in basis may be
represented the disease progressed very
clumsily so
the optima term of specimen collection
should be as close to symptom onset as
possible so repeat sampling is needed to
increase detection probability
especially when patient comes like we're
seeing the three days before and to
three days after a symptom onset so to
eat do sedate the optima numbers and
types of specimen collection for
effective in initial confirmation of the
Kobe 19 patients we calculate the
accumulative positive rate of
consecutive sample from the Kobe 19
patients for the most frequently
collected upper respiratory tracts
basement
75% of patient had a positive result
after one swab collection so eighty one
point seven percent patients had a
positive result after two consecutive
swab and 85.2% patient had positive
result after three consecutive swabs
but even until seven consecutive swabs
the positive results rate cannot reach
90 percent so we include a sputum for
the testing we can see the cumulative
positive rates increased rapidly from
eighty three point seven for first swab
rapidly increased to 90.2% after true
swabs and two samples and ninety four
percent after three samples
so take take this results we can suggest
many combination of minimum ones butan
with one upper respiratory tract
spaceman well be better than used upper
respiratory tract spaceman along the
better so to find whether antibody tests
could be our turn to use IC for early
diagnosis of Coby 19 we recruit 74
patients and consecutively tested their
IgM and IgG will see mera i see within
one month after symptom onset as showing
this finger antibody levels of posts IgM
and IgG
increase as time however the positive
rates of post antibodies in the first
week were only around 40% increased to
about 75% in second week and reached 90%
on t on the third week so based on this
read out steps Liberty IC testing is the
best test for early diagnosis of Cohen
19 and antibody testing could be a
supplementary of course we are looking
forward for the antigen testing come out
soon so taking together to improve early
diagnostic efficiency of liberal IC
testing for Koval 19 combination of
minimum one sputum with upper
respiratory tract swabs is good choice
consecutively sampling at this time as
close sometimes ed as possible will be
better the antibody testing not for
early diagnosis of the Kobe 19
so being at the end I would like to
thank sutram provincial health
commission for providing the data of our
study and I really appreciate our
hospital and department for supporting
the study and have many thanks to my
colleagues for hard work to fight the
virus with me together thank thank you
so much for your attention thank you dr.
Li Jie for your informative presentation
as a reminder our speaker will follow up
with any questions you have submitted
via email following this webinar we
would also like to thank labyrinths for
underwriting today's educational web
pass before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of this
year 2020 labret will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues whom they have missed it
is by the event until next time goodbye